Trascrizione: Tania Piorino
Revisore: Alessandro Lai
(Applausi)
Questa e' Giulia.
Giulia ha 4 anni e mezzo
e come tutti bambini di quell'età
passa suo tempo a osservare le cose
attorno a lei e chiedersi:
"Com'è fatto questo? Come funziona?
E sopratutto, perché funziona così?"
L'altro giorno Giulia mi ha sporto
un bicchiere d'acqua e mi ha chiesto:
"Papà, da che cosa è fatto
questo bicchiere d'acqua?"
Io di mestiere faccio
il fisico delle particelle
e quindi non ho esitato un momento
a rispondere:
"Beh, quel bicchiere d'acqua è fatto
da 3 milioni di miliardi di miliardi
di molecole d'acqua",
con un conticino facile facile
che tutti gli studenti delle scuole
superiori sono in grado di fare.
Naturalmente la risposta
non l'ha soddisfatta per niente.
"Che cos'è una molecola d'acqua?"
mi ha chiesto?
Al ché le ho fatto questo disegno,
le ho detto:
"Una molecola d'acqua
è un composto chimico
fatto da un atomo di ossigeno
e due atomi di idrogeno."
"Che cos'è un atomo?"
mi ha chiesto a quel punto.
"Beh, un atomo è la più piccola parte
di un elemento chimico fatto da un nucleo
attorno al quale ronzano delle particelle
che chiamiamo elettroni."
E lei ancora: "Che cosa è un nucleo?
Che cosa sono gli elettroni?"
E ho capito che non me la sarei
cavata facilmente.
Ho notato per terra, sul pavimento
del salotto, come in tutte le case
dove ci sono bambini di quella età,
un mucchio di Lego sparpagliato,
e così ho cominciato a spiegarle:
"Guarda, tutto quello che ci circonda -
e quando dico tutto, penso veramente
a me, te, la mamma, il bicchiere d'acqua,
i fiori, le stelle -
è fatto da un numero molto limitato
di piccoli mattoncini
che chiamiamo particelle."
Ho cominciato a raccogliere i pezzetti
di Lego ed ad allinearli sul tavolo.
Ne è venuto fuori uno schema
di questo genere:
tutta la materia che ci circonda
è fatta da dodici particelle
di due tipi che chiamiamo leptoni e quark,
ma divisi in tre famiglie di quattro
che vedete li allineati in colonna,
sotto i pezzettoni gialli.
E queste particelle si parlano tra di loro
tramite lo scambio di altre particelle
- sono come dei messaggeri,
o dei guardiani dello zoo, se volete.
Quella che tutti conoscono è il fotone,
il mattoncino rosso,
il granello di luce, il messaggero
dell'interazione elettromagnetica.
Ma poi ce ne sono altre:
per esempio i gluoni,
il mattoncino trasparente,
che incollano insieme i quark
dentro i nuclei degli atomi.
E due meno note agli altri, i mattoncini
verdi: il bosone W e il bosone Z.
Sono le particelle per cui Carlo Rubbia
ha vinto il Nobel nel 1984,
che trasportano l'interazione debole.
Allora vedete, potete mettervi a giocare
con queste particelle,
un po' come con il Lego,
e per esempio potete mettere insieme
due quark up e un quark down
- i fisici danno sempre dei nomi
bizzarri alle particelle -
due mattoncini azzurri
e uno azzurro più chiaro,
incollarle con dei gluoni
e fare un protone.
Oppure due quark down e un quark up
e fare un neutrone.
Adesso con un protone e un neutrone
potete fare in varie quantità
tutti in nuclei atomici possibili.
Per esempio, nel modo più semplice:
potete prendere un protone
e metterci un elettrone a ronzare intorno,
tenuto a lazo dal fotone del campo
elettromagnetico, ed ecco
che avete fatto un atomo di idrogeno.
Uno di quelli che stava nella molecola
d'acqua che abbiamo visto prima.
E i bosoni W e Z sono un po' i maghi
della compagnia, sono quelli che
si permettono di trasformare
una particella nell'altra --
per esempio: un quark up in quark down
o viceversa,
un neutrone in un protone dunque,
emettendo allo stesso tempo
elettroni e neutrini --
una reazione che vi sembrerà
esotica e forse inutile,
ma grazie alla quale
il nostro sole brilla.
Giulia ci mette sempre un sacco di tempo
a rimettere a posto tutti i suoi giochi.
Il Lego rimane spesso sparpagliato
sul tappeto del salotto.
Ha quindi guardato questo schema così
preciso, così ordinato e mi ha chiesto:
"Quanto tempo ci avete messo
a fare tutto quest'ordine?"
In effetti, c'è voluto un po', se pensate
che il primo mattoncino scoperto,
l'elettrone, è stato scoperto nel 1897
dal signor Thomson in Inghilterra,
e per trovare l'ultimo pezzettino
ci sono voluti più di 100 anni.
Il neutrino del Tau è stato scoperto
nel 2000 dalla collaborazione Donut,
che vuol dire ciambella
- non perché ne mangiassero tante ma
perché l'esperimento ci assomigliava -
più di cento anni dopo
per completare il quadro.
A questo punto Giulia mi ha guardato
con aria un po' perplessa e mi ha detto:
"Ma se avete messo tutto in ordine,
se comprendete così bene come si mettono
insieme i pezzettini che compongono
tutto quello che ci circonda,
ma tu, papà, che cosa fai
di lavoro allora?" (Risate)
E in effetti è una domanda ragionevole
perché uno potrebbe
essere [portato a pensare]
che questo splendido schema,
che normalmente noi chiamiamo
il modello standard, tra di noi,
spieghi veramente tutto.
E lo fà, per molti versi.
Ma gronda anche di domande,
di perché -- non risposte.
Allora noi normalmente non lo disegniamo
sulle lavagne sotto forma di mattoncino,
normalmente lo disegniamo
sotto forma di equazioni.
Vi ho preso la più semplice possibile
perché è sabato mattina per tutti.
Questa equazione descrive più o meno
quello che vi ho raccontato adesso
e funziona veramente benissimo.
Ma ha un sacco di difetti, per dirne una:
descrive le particelle come se
le particelle non avessero massa.
Ma noi sappiamo che le particelle hanno
una massa, è una cosa che misuriamo.
E dunque? Dov'è il problema?
Beh, questo è un caso tipico
che vi spiega come i fisici
tentano di risolvere i problemi.
Perché le particelle hanno massa?
Perché il bosone W doppio o il bosone Z
pesano 80 o 90 volte più di un protone
quando la nostra equazione li trattano
come se non avessero massa per niente?
Qualcuno di noi si è messo alla lavagna,
per esempio questo signore,
si chiama Peter Higgs, e nel 1964
pensò che poteva aggiungere
un pezzo all'equazione che vi ho mostrato,
quel pezzo disegnato in arancione,
che non vi chiedo
di comprendere nel dettaglio,
ma che rispettava la capacità
di predire come funziona
il mondo delle prime equazioni
spiegando allo stesso tempo
perché le particelle hanno massa.
Che cosa ha fatto Peter Higgs?
Ha immaginato che le particelle
in effetti non avessero massa
ma che nel mondo esistesse
una sorta di substrato,
che chiamiamo il campo di Higgs,
al quale le particelle senza massa
si appiccicano in modo più o meno forte
e quelle che ci si appiccicano più forte
sembra abbiano una massa più grande,
mentre alcune, come il fotone,
il mattoncino rosso,
non si appiccicano per nulla,
e ci appaiono come senza massa.
La cosa geniale di una teoria
di questo genere,
non è soltanto che spiega
un fenomeno della natura,
ma che ne predice di nuovi
e che dunque, andando a scoprire
se questi fenomeni nuovi predetti
sono veri,
possiamo capire se la teoria è reale,
se la natura veramente ha scelto
questo meccanismo per dare massa
alle particelle in questo caso.
Nel caso della teoria del signor Higgs,
la cosa interessante è che questo
substrato a cui particelle si appiccicano,
ogni tanto si raggruma su se stesso,
dando vita a una nuova particella
che tutti conoscono come
il bosone di Higgs, ma se preferite
noi potremmo chiamare
il mattoncino blu con le rotelle gialle
stamattina, perché siamo tra amici.
Come si fa ad andare a cercare
una nuova particella per vedere se esiste?
Beh, nel caso del bosone di Higgs
è stato necessario mettere in piedi
il più grande esperimento
scientifico della storia dell'uomo.
Dove lavoro io, al CERN di Ginevra,
laboratorio Europeo
per la fisica delle particelle,
ci sono venti stati europei più
altri sessanta stati del mondo
che si sono messi insieme per fornire
circa diecimila tra fisici e ingegneri,
per costruire il più grande acceleratore
di particelle del mondo, il più potente:
LHC, il Grande Collisionatore di Adroni.
Di cosa si tratta?
LHC è un tunnel di 27 km
scavato a circa 100 metri sottoterra,
all'interno del quale
prendiamo dei protoni
- vi ricordate, quelli fatti
con i mattoncini azzurri e blu -
e li facciamo circolare all'interno,
a una velocità pari a 99,99999%
della velocità della luce.
Pensate che a questa velocità
i protoni fanno
undicimila giri completi dell'anello
in un secondo.
Immaginate qual'è la complicazione
di tenerli in strada
perché non escano nelle curve.
E quando hanno raggiunto
questa velocità così grande,
li facciamo scontrare
gli uni contro gli altri,
perché tutta l'energia che hanno
messo insieme possa liberarsi
per costruire nuove particelle,
perché si ricreino
le condizioni iniziali dell'universo,
in cui è più probabile
vedere apparire queste
particelle nuove.
E come facciamo a vedere?
Beh, nei punti dove
i protoni si scontrano,
abbiamo costruito giganteschi rivelatori.
Quando dico giganteschi --
questo è Atlas,
il rivelatore a cui lavoro io --
questo signore è lungo 40 metri
e alto 20 metri.
Se guardate bene, vedete che
ci sono delle piccole figurine
- non stiamo li di solito,
a 100 metri sotto terra,
ma serve a darvi una idea
di quanto è grosso quest'oggetto.
In sostanza questo
è un enorme macchina fotografica,
capace di scattare 40 milioni
di fotografie al secondo
di quello che succede
durante le collisioni,
e delle tracce che lasciano le particelle
che sono state prodotte.
E dunque i miei colleghi ed io
- siamo circa tremila che lavoriamo
a questo esperimento -
scremiamo le particelle e le fotografie
delle particelle prese,
40 milioni di fotografie al secondo,
per vedere se ci sono le tracce
dell'apparizione di particelle nuove.
E allora si!
Può succedere, come è stato detto prima
e come avete letto sui giornali,
che a un certo punto nei nostri rilevatori
appaiano le tracce dell'apparizione
di un bosone di Higgs
o di un carrettino blu
con le rotelle gialle...
E che si, il 4 luglio scorso abbiamo
potuto annunciare al mondo
che questa particella
esiste, o per lo meno qualcuno,
una particella che gli assomiglia molto
e che sembra proprio che --
un meccanismo simile
a quello che nel 1964, 48 anni fa,
il signor Higgs aveva inventato
sulla sua lavagna, sia quello
che la natura ha scelto
per dare massa alle particelle.
Adesso immagino
che sarebbe bello dirvi
che questa scoperta
l'abbiamo fatta solo noi,
ma in realtà è una scoperta a cui
avete partecipato tutti perché il CERN,
i suoi laboratori,
l'acceleratore e i rivelatori
sono stati finanziati
da ognuno di voi.
Ognuno di voi ha messo l'equivalente
di circa un caffè,
del costo di un caffè all'anno
negli ultimi dieci anni,
o se preferite del costo di dieci caffè.
E non so voi, ma a me, questo
sembra un investimento molto interessante
per il ritorno che c'è stato.
(Applausi)
Ma a questo punto mi immagino che
voi seduti qui vi stiate facendo la stessa
domanda che si faceva Giulia all'inizio:
abbiamo aggiunto un altro mattoncino
al nostro mucchio, abbiamo capito,
e dunque adesso,
che cosa facciamo?
Che cosa continuerò a fare io
di lavoro in questo momento?
Abbiamo risolto tutto?
Abbiamo capito tutto come funziona?
Magari fosse così...
In realtà ci sono ancora un sacco
di domande da rispondere.
Vi faccio qualche esempio.
Per esempio:
perché c'è più materia che antimateria?
Le nostre equazioni ci dicono
che per ognuna delle particelle
esiste una particella uguale in tutto
tranne che nella carica elettrica,
come un gemello allo specchio,
e che quando una particella
incontra la sua anti particella
queste fanno ... puff!!
e spariscono lasciando
un granello di luce al loro posto,
in un processo
che chiamiamo annichilazione.
Le nostre equazioni ci dicono
che c'è una simmetria perfetta
fra materia e antimateria.
Ma se è così,
perché noi siamo fatti di materia?
Perché tutto quello che vediamo
è fatto di materia, e l'antimateria
dobbiamo andarla a cercare con il lumicino
all'interno dei nostri esperimenti.
E se la materia e l'antimateria
spariscono lasciando soltanto
granelli di luce,
perché l'universo non è fatto
solo di granelli di luce?
Non ne abbiamo idea.
E perché particelle simili che nelle
nostre equazioni giocano lo stesso ruolo
hanno masse così diverse?
Perché il muone pesa
200 volte più dell'elettrone?
Perché il tau pesa 16 volte più del muone
e più di tremila volte l'elettrone?
Non ne abbiamo idea.
Già che ci siamo, perché ci sono tre
famiglie di particelle quando in realtà
per costruire tutto quello che ci circonda
ci bastano i mattoncini della prima,
i mattoncini azzurri e blu,
gli elettroni e i neutrini
che vi ho mostrato?
Cosa servono le altre due famiglie?
E già che ci siamo, perché ce ne sono tre
e non due o quattro o cinque?
Non ne abbiamo idea.
E dove sono le particelle
di materia oscura, quelle i cui effetti
vediamo molto chiaramente
quando guardiamo il moto delle galassie
ma di cui nessuno ha visto le tracce
all'interno dei nostri esperimenti?
Non ne abbiamo idea.
E allora continuiamo a chiederci,
come i bambini di 4 anni e mezzo:
"Com'è fatto quello che ci circonda,
noi stessi? Perché è fatto così?"
Alcuni di noi lo fanno di fronte
alla lavagna, come il signor Higgs,
cercando di estendere
ancora le nostre teorie,
o di inventarne di completamente nuove.
Altri, come i miei colleghi e me,
a scavare nell'intimità più profonda
e minuscola della natura,
con la speranza di trovare tracce
che confermino la bontà
delle nostre nuove teorie
o che ci diano degli indizi
per formularne di alternative.
Con questa ambizione profonda
di poter spiegare guardando
nell'infinitamente piccolo come
funziona tutto, e l'nfinitamente grande.
Si, perché, vedete, questa è veramente
l'ambizione che noi abbiamo,
della storia che vogliamo raccontare:
è la storia dello stesso
mucchio di particelle
di cui vi ho parlato fino ad adesso
che circa 14 miliardi di anni fa
stava confinata in uno spazio
non più grande di quello che oggi
è occupato da un singolo atomo,
di quello in cui ci sono
3 milioni di miliardi di miliardi
dentro un bicchiere d'acqua.
E poi a un certo punto, per ragioni
di nuovo che non comprendiamo molto bene,
questo spazio ha
incominciato ad espandersi,
prima più velocemente
poi più lentamente.
Il campo di Higgs è intervenuto
e ha dato massa alle particelle.
Ha differenziato il modo
in cui l'interazione debole
e l'interazione elettromagnetica
si comportano.
La gravità è un'altra di quelle cose
che non comprendiamo molto bene.
Ha cominciato a comportarsi
anch'essa in modo diverso.
La materia si è annichilita
con l'antimateria,
ma ce n'era un po' di più,
per ragioni che non comprendiamo,
è rimasta in giro un po' di materia,
i quark si sono messi insieme,
hanno formato i primi protoni,
gli elettroni hanno cominciato
a ronzare intorno, si sono formati
i primi atomi di idrogeno e di elio,
in 400 milioni di anni.
Le prime stelle hanno cominciato
a brillare, e nel cuore delle stelle,
come in gigantesche fornaci cosmiche,
gli elementi più pesanti si sono formati:
il carbonio, l'azoto, l'ossigeno,
tutto quello che serve a fare l'acqua
e gli elementi che formano la vita
che conosciamo sul nostro pianeta.
Pensate che se
l'intensità dell'interazione debole,
quella mediata dai mattoncini verdi,
fosse stata un briciolo diversa
da quella che misuriamo,
l'ossigeno o il carbonio nel cuore
delle stelle non sarebbero stati stabili,
non ci sarebbe stata l'acqua,
non ci sarebbe stata la vita,
e noi oggi non saremmo qui,
a raccontare questa storia
e ad immaginare nel futuro.
E perché è così?
Non ne abbiamo idea.
(Applausi)
Alla fine dell'ottocento,
quando l'unica della particelle
che vi ho mostrato nota era
l'elettrone, il mattoncino giallo,
alcuni fisici si spingevano
a dire che la scienza era finita
e che da quel momento in poi la fisica
si sarebbe solo occupata
di misurare in modo più preciso
cose che già conoscevamo.
I cento anni che sono venuto dopo
hanno portato numerose rivoluzioni
nel nostro modo di vedere il mondo
e li hanno smentiti clamorosamente,
e posso garantirvi che oggi nessuno di noi
oserebbe dire una cosa di questo genere.
Per tante cose che abbiamo scoperto
e che conosciamo di più
rispetto ai nostri colleghi
di più di un secolo fa,
ce ne sono altrettante che non conosciamo.
E se volete, la consapevolezza
di questa ignoranza
è quello che ci spinge
a continuare a cercare.
Allora è chiaro che la consapevolezza
di questa ignoranza può anche fare paura,
perché siamo abituati a pensare
alla scienza come ad una disciplina
che ha le risposte,
alla quale gli si può rivolgere.
E invece la vediamo spesso
come una disciplina
che ha certe risposte ma
ha spesso più domande che risposte.
Non crediate che i fisici
siano immuni a questa paura.
Albert Einstein, uno dei più famosi fisici
e più conosciuti nel secolo scorso, diceva:
"Chiunque di fronte
ai misteri dell'universo
rimane shockato, come paralizzato
dall'immensità di quello che ci circonda
e della difficoltà
di comprenderne il senso.
Ma diceva anche che
di fronte a questo shock,
l'importante è non smettere
mai di farsi domande.
Come bambini di 4 anni e mezzo,
continuiamo ad esercitare
la nostra curiosità.
Grazie.
(Applausi)